OKAY. THIS. YEAH OKAY. ALL RIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME I
WOULD LIKE TO CONVENE THE
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE THE SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND JUST
TO NOTE NUMBERS GOING BACK AND
FORTH FROM THE SWING SPACE TO
DIFFERENT COMMITTEE ROOM SO
PEOPLE WILL BE COMING IN AND OUT
AS WE WAIT FOR A QUORUM I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN- AS A SUB SUB COMMITTEE
AND WITH A FEW- PROTOCOL UP
PLEASE BE AWARE ALL WITNESS
TESTIMONY WILL BE IN PERSON
THERE WILL BE NO PHONE TESTIMONY
OPTION FOR THIS HEARING. FOR THE
BILLS BEING TAKEN UP TODAY WE
WILL TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WITH TWO MINUTES EACH
THESE WITNESSES- AS I SAID WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES ALL SUBSEQUENT
TO WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE HEARING
ROOM AND HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND BEGAN WE HAVE THREE BILLS ON
PROPOSED CONSENT FILE ITEM ONE.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR
RODRIGUEZ FILE ITEM SIX AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY. ME A BONTA
AND FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY TWO WOOD- THIS
CONCLUDES OUR- HOUSEKEEPING AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND I DO
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER- GRAYSON.
AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CALL YOU
UP SINCE YOU ARE HERE.
PRESENTING AB. TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTEEN.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTEEN WHICH WILL UPDATE
SAFETY TRAINING FOR RIDE SHARE
DRIVERS AND REQUIRE THEM TO TAKE
TRAINING EVERY TWO YEARS OVER
THE PAST DECADE TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES LIKE UBER LIFT
HAVE BECOME AMBIGUOUS ACROSS THE
STATE WHILE THESE COMPANIES IN
THE DRIVERS PROVIDE IMPORTANT
SERVICES TO MANY CALIFORNIANS
WHEN YOU ENTER A CAR WITH A
STRANGER YOU HAND YOUR SAFETY
OVER TO THEM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ALREADY RECALL THERE'S TNCS TO
PROVIDE SAFETY TRAINING TO THEIR
DRIVERS HOWEVER THE CPUC
CURRENTLY DOES NOT SPECIFY WHAT
THAT TRAINING. MUST INCLUDE
ITEMIZED EXPERIENCED WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO BE IN A COLLISION WHILE
USING A RIGHT SHOWS RIGHT
SERVICE AND HE'S TRYING TO
TRAFFIC COLLISIONS ARE DANGEROUS
THEY'RE FRIGHTENING AND IN MANY
CASES ARE PREVENTABLE I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE SERVICE THAT
RIGHT SHARES AND THEIR DRIVERS
PROVIDE BUT IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT DRIVERS WHO ARE
TRANSPORTING PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEHIND THE WHEEL THE MOST ARE UP
TO DATE ON THEIR SAFE DRIVING
SKILLS AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN
IS A SIMPLE. TO READ DRIVERS TO
ENSURE DRIVERS RECEIVE TRAINING
ON DEFENSIVE DRIVING DISTRACTED
DRIVING AND- YES COOLEY IS AT NO
COST TO THE DRIVER THIS WILL
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF PASSENGERS
DRIVERS AND PEDESTRIANS ALIKE
AND I DO HAVE WITNESSED. ME TO.
WITH IMPROPER K. INSURANCE
ASSOCIATES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIR. HE SAID THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- DENNY WRITER
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION WE'RE A NATIONAL
TRADE REPRESENT ABOUT 60% OF THE
PROPERTY AND CASUALTY MARKET-
WE'RE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON'S BILL AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTEEN WHICH IS HE INDICATED
WOULD MANDATE- REQUIRED TRAINING
EVERY TWO YEARS FOR TNC DRIVERS-
WE AT WITHIN THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
PROACTIVE EFFORTS TO EDUCATE
DRIVERS ON SAFE DRIVING
PRACTICES- AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THE- THESE
DRIVERS EVE. IS EFFECTIVE AND
COMPREHENSIVE AND WILL IMPROVE
THE SAFETY OF PASSENGERS AND
PEDESTRIANS ALIKE SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU- AND WITH THAT WE'LL SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS IN THE ROOM. NOT SEEN
WE- YEAH AND TO. WHICH WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
BE IN OPPOSITION. SO A WE WERE
FIRST LOOKING FOR SUPPORT ANY.
INDIVIDUAL IN THE ROOM THEY'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. NOT
SEEN ANY WE HAVE ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. NOT SEEN ANYBODY WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
AUTHOR- FOR ANY ORDERS TO THE
COMMITTEE IF ANY. QUESTIONS FROM
OUR COMMITTEE. NO QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND BACK TO OUR
AUTHOR MANAGER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT BUT WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. ALL RIGHT AND AS WE
ARE NOT FULL COMMITTEE YET TO WE
WILL. GET BACK TO YOU ON WHERE
THAT HEADS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. ALL RIGHT DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER- I SEE MISTER
GIPSON MR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON PRESENTING AB.
TWENTY
SEVEN ZERO TWO.
WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR I
THINK THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
PRESENTING- BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND- INTO YOURSELF SO
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE CHAIR INTO- THE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN TWO. WHICH SEEKS TO
PROVIDE RELIABLE INTERNET
CONNECTION TO FAMILIES LIVING IN
PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING FIRST
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND COMMITTEE CHAIR I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS- IN
ORDER TO STRENGTHEN IN MAKING
THIS BILL BETTER SO WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR
THAT SPECIFICALLY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN OH TWO WHAT
PRIORITIZE. GRANTS AND LOANS FOR
PUBLIC FOR THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO- PER TO PUBLICLY
SUPPORTED- HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CURRENTLY IT IS NOT POSSIBLE FOR
MANY OF PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING COMPLEXES EVEN ACCESS
BROADBAND ARE THESE BUILDINGS
ARE VERY OLD. LACK NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURES TO PROVIDE HIGH
SPEED QUALITY INTERNET SERVICE
THESE FUNDS ARE IMPERATIVE OF
FOR THE REASONS BECAUSE THE COST
OF RETROFITTING THESE BUILDINGS
ARE ABSOLUTELY EXPENSIVE TO
ORGANIZATIONS AND TO OWNERS WHO
ALL THESE COMPLEX- THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
AT THE FOREFRONT OF FIGHTING FOR
THE DIGITAL QUALITY CALIFORNIA
HAS NOT DONE ENOUGH IN
UNDERSCORE HAVE NOT DEPEND IN.
WHEN SURE DIGITAL EQUITY IS IN
EVERY COMMUNITY AND THE RESULT
IS THAT PEOPLE ARE BEING LEFT
OUT. ONE CALIFORNIA. THAT IS
CONNECTED AND ONE CALIFORNIA
THAT IS NOT ONE CALIFORNIA THAT
HAS INFRASTRUCTURE CONNECTION
AND ONE CALIFORNIA THAT DOES NOT
WHEN COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
CONNECTED WE ALL SUFFER
DISCONNECTING POPULATIONS. DOES
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO TELEMEDICINE
AND EXPRESSLY DOING THIS
PANDEMIC I HAVE PEOPLE MY OWN
COMMUNITY WHO HAD HAD TO MANAGE-
THIS PANDEMIC BUT ALSO NOT BEING
CONNECTED. ARE BECAUSE THEY WERE
NOT CONNECTED BECAUSE OF THEM
LIVING IN PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING NO CONNECTION MEANS NO A
COVERT TESTING NO VACCINES NO
COVERT TESTING MEANS NO.
SPREADING OF THIS PANDEMIC
DISCONNECTING POPULATIONS CAN'T
APPLY FOR JOBS ONLINE NO JOBS.
AND THE POSSIBILITIES OF
VIOLENCE INCREASE FATHER BOYLE
SAID THIS GIVE A MAN A WOMAN A
JOB YOU STOP A BULLET. BUT YOU
CAN'T STOP A BULLET OF A PERSON
DON'T HAVE A JOB AND WE WANT
THEM TO HAVE ALTERNATIVES AND
HOW DO WE HAVE HUNDRED COMPANY
HAVE ALTERNATIVES IF THEY'RE NOT
CONNECTED EXPRESSLY- AND IT'S
TIME THAT WE'RE LIVING IN RIGHT
NOW WITH THIS PANDEMIC. MEMBERS
AS YOU KNOW FAMILIES LIVING IN
PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING ARE
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS 30% OF ALL RESIDENTS
MAKING UNDER. TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ARE ON CONNECTED TO THE
INTERNET AND HAVING BROADBAND
SERVICE 49% OF THE PEOPLE
WITHOUT HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION
ARE NOT CONNECTED 35% OF NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING LATINO
POPULATIONS ARE NOT CONNECTED
30% OF ALL SENIOR CITIZENS ARE
UNDER CONNECTED SIXTY TWO
PERCENT. OF UNCONNECTED
HOUSEHOLDS WERE NOT AWARE OF LOW
INCOME PLANS THAT WERE MADE
ABOUT THEM DURING THIS PANDEMIC
. IN SPAIN IN CLOSING I SIMPLY
SAY WE CANNOT HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA'S IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE CONNECT EVERYONE WE
CANNOT HAVE THE HAVE AND HAVE
NOT WE COULD NOT HAVE. CHILDREN
IN THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE
GOING TO CONNECT IN THE GARAGE
JEFF THE TAP INTO THE NEIGHBOR'S
DAY INTENDED IN ARKANSAS AND IN
ORDER AND TO HOLD A- THAT YOU
KNOW NOT. CALIFORNIANS FALL AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL. I DON'T KNOW WHO IS
SPEAKING TO BUT ANYWAY. A TWENTY
SEVEN A BILL TWENTIETH OH TO
SPEAK TO THE VERY THING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ONE CALIFORNIA
THAT EVERYONE IS CONNECTED. HERE
WITH ME IS SENDING BACK PEAK THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGING TECHNOLOGY-
FOUNDER AND ALSO SENATOR RICHARD
POLANCO WHICH ADDITIONAL QUALITY
COALITION WHO WILL- TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN OH TO. THANK YOU ARE
BEFORE YOU HEAR THE TESTIMONY
WE'RE GONNA IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE ARE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL INTO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS IS
FOR QUORUM QUIRK-SILVA. HERE
QUIRK-SILVA PRESIDENT PATTERSON
PATTERSON PRESIDENT
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA SAID
AVANTE THIS DAVIES DAVIS PRESENT
GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN PRESIDENT
LO LO PRESENT MAIENSCHEIN
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ PRESIDENT
VALLADARES OF DAR'S PRESIDENT DR
WEBER DR WEBER PRESIDENT. ALL
RIGHT DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON THE CONSENT. MOTION OF
EMOTIONAL BLOW A SECOND INVOLVED
ERIS. L- AND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR
THE DO PASSED AS AMEND. A. B.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY AND A. B.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY TWO TO PASS
ALL GO TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. QUIRK-SILVA HI
QUIRK-SILVA I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA CERVANTES DAVIES DAVIES I
GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN I LOW LOW
AYE MAIENSCHEIN RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I VALLADARES VOTERS HI
DOCTOR WEBER DR WEBER I. ALL
RIGHT- WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
OUR WITNESSES ANDA PLEASE GO
AHEAD MANAGED CARE I'M SENDING
THE PEAK THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MERGING TECHNOLOGY
FUND I WANT TO BEGIN BY
FURTHERING THE MIKE CLOSER TO
YOU KNOW OKAY. YOU CAN HEAR ME
BETTER NOW RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY- OF SYSTEMIC PICK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MERGING
TECHNOLOGY FUND- MAY BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU MISTER GIBSON FOR
CONTINUING TO RAISE THIS ISSUE
AND FOR ALL OF YOU MEMBERS TO
LAST YEAR'S SPOKE OUT IN FAVOR
OF GETTING EVERY RESIDENT AND
PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
CONNECTED. UNFORTUNATELY OF WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO GET THAT BILL
THROUGH HOWEVER YOU DID
APPROPRIATE A LOT OF MONEY THAT
IS AVAILABLE WHAT WE'RE COMING
TO YOU TO S. TODAY WITH TWENTY
SEVEN OH TWO IT'S JUST
PRIORITIZE THE FUNDING TO
PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
COMPLEXES THERE ARE MORE THAN
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED SUCH
COMPLEXES IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
AND AT LEAST 40% OF THOSE
RESIDENTS ARE NOT CONNECTED AND
HAVE NO ACCESS. TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET SERVICE. IN MISTER
GIBSON'S DISTRICT OF THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- OVER HALF 50% OF THEIR
COMPLEX IT'S STILL ARE NOT
CONNECTED WITH HIGH SPEED
INTERNET SERVICE. WE KNOW THESE
THESE- COMPLEXES JORDON DOWNS-
MAR VISTA GARDENS NICKERSON- IN
FRESNO- THE HOUSING AUTHORITY AT
LEAST HALF OF THOSE COMPLEXES
ARE NOT CONNECTED. SO IN
CONCLUSION LET ME JUST SAY OUT
OF ALL OF THE AMAZING COMMITMENT
YOU'VE MADE AS THE LEGISLATURE
TO BROADBAND GETTING PEOPLE
CONNECTED. IN TEN YEARS NO MORE
THAN FIFTEEN MILLION HAS
ACTUALLY GONE TO THOSE PEOPLE
AND PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING.
THAT ARE THE MOST IMPOVERISHED
THERE THE POOREST CALIFORNIANS
BY DEFINITION THAT IS HOW THEY
QUALIFY TO LIVE IN A GOVERNMENT
HOUSING AUTHORITY OR NONPROFIT.
OR DOUBLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
IT'S TIME THAT WE ACTUALLY
COMMUNICATE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION YOUR PRIORITY
THANK YOU. THAT'S AHEAD TOUGH
ONE TO FOLLOW MADAM CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SO RICHARD POLANCO
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS GREAT
INSTITUTION REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
FUND AND THE DIGITAL COALITION
EQUITY COALITION I'LL JUST BE
VERY BRIEF 40% THAT ARE. NOT
CONNECTED IN THE PUBLIC HOUSING
. COMPLEX'S IN CALIFORNIA OF THE
MANY IT'S NOT AN ISSUE S. B. ONE
FIFTY SIX YOUR ALLOCATED THIS
BODY ALLOCATED SIX BILLION WITH
THREE BILLION GOING TO OF THE
MIDDLE MILE- THIS BILL. WILL
APPROPRIATE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE- NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. COOPER TO BE TARGETED TO
THE MOST BONE UP VULNERABLE
DISADVANTAGED BOTH IN RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES AND THAT
INCLUDES OUR FARMWORKERS THERE'S
A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT AS WE
KNOW THAT WAS ILLUMINATED BY
VIRTUE OF THE PANDEMIC- AND-
THIS IS A POPULATION THAT CANNOT
BE LEFT BEHIND WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU NEXT WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM AND YOU MAY.
JOIN US AT THE MICROPHONE PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. RIGHT NOT SEEN
ANY OTHER SUPPORT IN THE ROOM-
WE WILL GO TO ANY OPPOSITION.
NOT SEEN ANY OPPOSITION COMING
TO THE MICROPHONE WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SO I
THINK WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOAN AND A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OH I'M SORRY I DIDN'T SEE YOU
YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YES OKAY.
NOW THANK YOU. THE CHERUB RECCO
IS AN ONLINE. DO PASSED AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK-SILVA HI QUIRK-SILVA HI
PATTERSON PATTERSON I
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA SAID A
MONTH THIS DAVIES DAVIES I
GARCIA HOLDEN. HOLDEN I LO LOW
AYE MAIENSCHEIN RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I VALLADARES ELDERS I
DR WEBER DR WEBER HI. THIS AND
WE'RE GOING TO I WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT NEXT- WE WILL GO IN ORDER
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GO
WITH A HOLDEN I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING. BUT YES HE'S HERE TO.
WITH WITH WITH. WITH GRAYSON
ANDERSON. ALL RIGHT BEFORE WE
START WITH MISTER GRAYSON WE DID
HAVE A BILL THAT WE HEARD BEFORE
AND SUBCOMMITTEE- THAT WAS MR
GRAYSON'S BILL- DO WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE BY OF ALL
THERE IS A SECOND BY SOME MEMBER
DAVIS WOULD GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ROLL ON THAT ONE. THE CHERUB
GO IS IT I DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK-SILVA HI
QUIRK-SILVA HI PATTERSON
PATTERSON HI BOERNER HORVATH.
BONTA SAID AMOUNT THIS. DAVIES
DAVIES I GARCIA. ALL THEM HOLDEN
I LO LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I L. DERIS
BUILDERS I DOCTOR WEBER DR WEBER
I'M THE BILLS OUT AND WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN. ALL RIGHT THAT
THAT TAKES US TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
INDUSTRY AND PUBLIC ADVOCATES
CONCERNS. AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT WILL UPDATE AN ADDRESS
PERSISTENT ISSUES WITH THE
DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND VIDEO
COMPETITION ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX ALSO KNOWN AS DIFFICULT.
DIFFICULT WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN COURAGE
COMPETITION IN THE CABLE MARKET
WITH THE INTENT OF BENEFITING
CONSUMERS BY LOWERING PRICES IN
PROMOTING THE EXPANSION OF
SERVICES. SEVENTEEN YEARS LATER
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT THIS
APPROACH SELF REGULATING OF THE
INDUSTRY THROUGH COMPETITION HAS
FAILED. THERE'S LESS COMPETITION
IN THE MARKET PLACE THAN EVER
AND ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT
PUBLISHED BY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND HOME STATEWIDE REMAIN
COMPLETELY UNSERVED BY INTERNET
AND BROADBAND SERVICES. THAT
MEANS THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
THESE CALIFORNIA FAMILIES COULD
NOT ACCESS REMOTE SCHOOLING WORK
FROM HOME OPTIONS HEALTH
TELEHEALTH ONLINE APPLICATIONS
FOR ASSISTANCE THEY QUALIFY FOR
AND MORE. AND ANNOUNCED
INCONVENIENT AND INEQUITABLE
OBSTACLE FOR MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. THE PANDEMIC HAS
PROVEN THAT ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INTERNET SERVICES ARE NOT JUST
FOR ENTERTAINMENT BUT ARE
ESSENTIAL TOOLS FOR SURVIVAL. SO
EQUAL ACCESS IS A CRUCIAL PUBLIC
INTEREST FOR THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS REMAIN UNDERSERVED OR
COMPLETELY UNSERVED DUE TO
DIGITAL REDLINING UNEQUAL
PRICING AND TERMS THAT UNFAIRLY
DISADVANTAGE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. IN MY OWN DISTRICT
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A
CONSTITUENT FOR FOUR YEARS
REGARDING THEIR PERSONAL ISSUES
WITH RECEIVING FIBER INTERNET IN
THEIR HOME TO SUPPORT THEIR
BUSINESS. DESPITE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BEING PRESENT AND
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE THE SAME
FIBER INTERNET TO NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES MY CAN TO AND HAS
BEEN BIG EXPLANATIONS FROM
PROVIDERS ON WHY HIS BUSINESS
DOES NOT QUALIFY TO RECEIVE
FIBER INTERNET DESPITE. THE
PRESIDENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
UNFORTUNATELY MY CONSTITUENTS
SCENARIO IS NOT AN OUT LIAR
WHICH MAKES THE NEED FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT MORE
URGENT. THIS BILL WILL SEEK TO
REMEDY THESE ISSUES BY UPDATING
DISCRIMINATION PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS AND GRADING ALL
POTENTIAL AND EXISTING CUSTOMERS
WITH A RIGHT TO EQUAL ACCESS TO
SERVICES ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE WITHIN
FRANCHISE HOLDERS SERVICE
TERRITORIES ARE RECEIVING EQUAL
ACCESS. AND RATES OF SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WILL
ADOPT DEF THE DEFINITION OF DO
DIGITAL DISCRIMINATION USED IN
FEDERAL POLICY AND GRAB THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WITH THE SAME
AUTHORITY THEY WOULD HAVE. UNDER
FEDERAL LAW TO ENFORCE THE BUILD
OUT OF VIDEO AND CABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. BY DOING SO WE
CAN BRING THIS NEARLY TWO
DECADES OLD POLICY UP TO DATE
STANDARDS AND EXTEND CABLE VIDEO
AND BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
HOMES THAT CURRENTLY LACK THE
NECESSARY CONNECTIONS TO RECEIVE
THE SERVICE. FINALLY THIS BILL
WILL RENAME DIFFICULT. TO THE
DIGITAL EQUITY IN VIDEO-FRANCHISING ACT. OR DEFY. THE
HIGHLIGHT THE ULTIMATE POLICY
GOAL OF THIS BILL EQUITY IN
ACCESS TO VITAL SERVICES. I
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS THAT TOOK PLACE TO
ESTABLISH DIFFICULT FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS AGO. AND WITH MY
CAN COLLEAGUES SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WE CAN USE OUR PLATFORM TO
UPDATED TO BETTER MEET THE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIANS TODAY. OUR
PREDECESSORS WHO CREATED
DIFFICULT COULD NOT HAVE
ANTICIPATED A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
ACCELERATING THE TRANSITION OF
MANY ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO
ONLINE TODAY WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS CAN WITHSTAND
ANOTHER GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND
MAINTAIN INTER CONNECTED TO. THE
INTERCONNECTED THIS THROUGH
EQUAL ACCESS TO CRITICAL
SERVICES. ON THE LINE AND I ALSO
HEAR A PERSON ALONG- IS A
SUPPORT OF FROM- ANNA TERESA DE
HAND AND WITH GREAT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS NOW AND TRACY ROSENBERG
WITH MEDIA ALLIANCE. HI THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT. AND JUST CHECKING IN DO
YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS YES
I'D- OUR FIRST TESTIMONY THANK
YOU CHAIR AND THINK YOU MEMBERS
MY NAME IS I'M NOT THAT I SAID
THE HONDA NAME BE SENIOR
DIRECTOR ADEQUATE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
NOW A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
THAT FOCUSES ON IMPROVING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
OUTCOMES FOR LOS ANGELES
CHILDREN OF COLOR AND THOSE
LIVING IN POVERTY. AS OPPOSED
TRANSITION BACK AFTER MORE THAN
TWO YEARS OF COVERT RELATED
DISRUPTIONS IT'S CRITICAL THAT
ALL OF US EDUCATORS PARENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS STAY FOCUSED
ON AND DEEM. THE INEQUITIES OF
THE PANDEMIC EXPOSED AND
EXACERBATED IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
ONE OF THE MOST URGENT
INEQUITIES IS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
. IN OUR ANNUAL POLL OF LOS
ANGELES FAMILIES WE LEARNED THAT
84% A FAMILY SAY THEY STILL FACE
CHALLENGES ACCESSING THE
INTERNET AT HOME. THE TWO
BIGGEST REASONS THEY SHARED OUR
THAT THE INTERNET IS JUST TOO
EXPENSIVE AND INTERNET ACCESS
THAT IS AFFORDABLE IS TOO POOR
QUALITY TO MEET THEIR FAMILY
NEEDS. IN CALIFORNIA OVER 25% OF
K. TWELVE STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE
RELIABLE INTERNET ACCESS AT
HOME. AND 10% OF LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS RELYING ON
SMARTPHONES TO ACCESS THE
INTERNET. THIS MEANS THAT
WEALTHIER STUDENTS WHOSE
FAMILIES LIVE IN AREAS WITH
BETTER BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
HAVE AN EASIER TIME APPLYING FOR
COLLEGE FINING IN AND ROLLING IN
AND OUT OF SCHOOL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AND DOING THEIR
HOMEWORK. AS A RESULT OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE THERE ARE MANY
RESOURCES. FOR THE PANDEMIC
RECOVERY THAT BLACK AND LATINO
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS SIMPLY
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO. EVERY
FAMILY IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO EQUAL SERVICE WITH
EQUAL TERMS AND CONDITIONS NOT
SERVICE THAT IS DIFFERENTIATED
ON HOUSEHOLD INCOME OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND NOT PRICE
SCENE IN TERMS THAT ARE BETTER
FOR WEALTHY COMMUNITIES THAN FOR
LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS. THIS
IS WHY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
REFORMING AND UPDATING THE
NEARLY TWO DECADES OLD POLICY
THAT REGULATES THE STATE'S
LARGEST INTERNET SERVICE
COMPANIES. TO REQUIRE EQUAL
ACCESS IT'S NECESSARY AND URGENT
IT IS A NECESSARY AND URGENT
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLD THEM AND COCHAIR
QUIRK-SILVA FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU I WILL TRY
TO BE BRIEF MY NAME IS TRACY.
ROSENBERG I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
MEDIA ALLIANCE WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
COMMUNICATIONS ADVOCATE AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT UPDATES
A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD BELL.
DIFFICULTY WHICH MOVED CABLE
FRANCHISING FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROCESS TO THE CPUC
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHEN WE MADE
THE FIRST SMALL CHECK IMAGE TO.
DAVE BECAUSE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX WITH SB TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR CABALLERO IN ASSIGNING
MESSAGE GOVERNMENT. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM SAID I ENCOURAGE THE-
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER GOING
FURTHER IT HAS BEEN FIFTEEN
YEARS. INSTEAD OF CA AND THE
EXISTING STATUTE IS OUTDATED. WE
AGREE STATE CABLE FRANCHISES
CARI NUDE EVERY TEN YEARS THE
CURRENT PROCESS RUBBER STAMPS A
- RENEWAL AUTOMATICALLY AND CAN
WHAT'S THE APPLICANT IS
VIOLATING A NON APPEALABLE COURT
ORDER THAT IS A VERY LOW BAR
THIS PREVENTS THE STATE FROM
WORKING ON DIGITAL EQUITY GOALS
AND- DEALING WITH PROBLEMS LIKE
LACK OF ACCESS OR REDLINING. AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
BALANCES OUT THE RECORDS D.
REGULATORY PROCESS SO IT ISN'T
ONE SIDED AND CAN CONSIDER
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES AS DEFINED
IN THE BILL TO PROMOTE
WIDESPREAD ACCESS TO THE MOST
TECHNICAL TECHNOLOGICALLY
ADVANCED CABLE AND VIDEO
SERVICES TO ALL CALIFORNIANS IN
A NON. THE DISCRIMINATORY MANNER
REGARDLESS OF SOCIO ECONOMIC
STATUS IF THAT'S OUR GOAL AND
THE STATE PROCESS TO USE THE
PUBLIC RIGHTS OF WAY NEEDS O
REFLECT THOSE GOALS AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT IS NOT HEAVY
HANDED IT SIMPLY EMPOWERS THE
STATE TO. DELIVER ON ITS DIGITAL
EQUITY PROMISES TO CALIFORNIANS
BY NOT IGNORING EQUITY WHEN
ISSUING STATE FRANCHISES THIS IS
LONG OVERDUE AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
INVITE- THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. TO COME TO
THE MICROPHONE. OH I'M SORRY I'M
RUSHING AT SORRY EVERYBODY. WE
NEED OUR WITNESSES- FIRST IN
SUPPORT A WE JUST AN ART WE NEED
OUR OPPOSITION WITNESSES SORRY.
SO WE WERE ASK OUR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF BERNIE OROZCO
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION-
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S- INTENTIONS HERE TO
PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS TO ALL
CALIFORNIA SOMETHING THAT WE
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT AND
ATTEMPT TO DO. WE ARE HOWEVER
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS AND
ANNUAL PRIMARILY YOU'RE YOU'RE
USING A VIDEO FRANCHISING LAW TO
GO AFTER BROADBAND SO YOU'RE
TAKING A CODE SECTION THAT WAS
INTENDED TO STREAMLINE THE
COMPETITION A VIDEO SERVICE SO
WHEN SOMEONE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE YOUKNOW IT'S A QUICK
PROCESS FOR RENEWALS THAT IS BY
DESIGN SO. WHEN LLOYD LEVINE
AND- FARBEYOND WHEN YES
SPONSORED THIS LEGISLATION BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX IT WAS FOR
THAT PURPOSE BECAUSE OF THE-
PROCESS WITH HEAVY NEGOTIATIONS
ABOUT WHAT HOW MUCH WOULD YOU
PAY HOW MUCH PAY CHANNELS YOU
PROVIDE- YOU KNOW WHAT ACCESS
YOU GIVE TO FIRE STATIONS YOU
KNOW SCHOOLS. SO IF PARA SAYS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ALL THAT
PROCESS AND JUST SAY YOU GET 5%
OF YOUR GROSS RECEIPTS FOR-
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GET YOU.
FOR USE. WE DESIGNED TO BE A
VERY SMOOTH IS A PROCESS FOR-
APPLICATIONS AND RENEWALS. FOR
VIDEO SERVICE SO NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO USE- THIS FLAW THOUGH
FOR BROADBAND. AND THAT'S WHERE
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS BECAUSE
CONTRARY TO DIFFICULT THIS WILL
NOW GIVE THE PC LONG LENGTH THE
AUTHORITY TO HAVE LONG
PROCEEDINGS TO LOOK AT YOUR
DEPLOYMENT. FOR BROADBAND IN A
VIDEO FRANCHISE AT LAW. AND THE
CONCERN WITH THAT IS THAT. AGAIN
IT WAS NEVER. DO THAT BAD THAT
WHEN DID RULES ARE BEING
DESIGNED FOR DEAF GOT. THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED THE PC TO DO
WHAT'S PROPOSED IN THIS BILL.
AND THE P. YOU SEE SAID NOW
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS LAWS
DESIGNED TO DO. AND WHAT WOULD
BE EVERY TEN YEARS TO BRING IN A
FIVE AND- PARTIALLY SERVICE THIS
. WE HAVE THE ALL. STE HE'S IN
FOR NOT HI IT'S SO DON'T WAIT
TEN YEAR THAT OVER SHOULD BE ON
AND CONSTANT SO WE WERE
CONCERNED THIS YOU EXPANSION OF
THOR TO THE P. AND- IT'S CON TO
THE SIR THAT PROVIDED IN DIFF-
THE NEW AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE-
THAT WOULD GIVE THE YOU SEE THE
TORTURED ANY OF NEW REQUIRED
THIS BENNY KIND OF SRE OF
STRICT OUT AT THE THING WE AVOID
IT BACK INTO THE SIX. SO WE HAVE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR- WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS- WE
KNOW WE AGAIN SUPPORT EQUAL
ACCESS BORN IN. NEW UPDATED AND
OF BERRY TO DEPLOY. THAT THIS
BILL RE. SOBRE TO THAT THE- BARE
THOSE I DO BERRIES ARE RESTORED
- BUT WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS AND
IF IT EXPANSION OF THE PC ON
SOMETHING THAT WAS PURPOSELY
DESIGNED TO BE STREAMLINED.
THANK YOU NEXT WAS WITNESSED
CAROLINE BILL HUNTER SLOW HIS
JENSEN AND ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
OF DIRECT TV. DIRECT TV ALSO
OPPOSES AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT. AND WHILE WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE DESIRE TO PROVIDE
EQUITABLE ACCESS FOR ALL AND TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN THE
VIDEO AND BROADBAND MARKETPLACE.
THE BILL UNFORTUNATELY FAILED TO
CONSOLE THE UNIQUE STRUCTURE OF
THE DIRECT TV UNIVERSE
RELATIONSHIP WHAT DIRECT TV
BITES HOLD THE U. VERSE VIDEO
SERVICE FRANCHISE LICENSE FROM
THE CEBU CITY. IT DOES NOT OWN
CONTROL THE NETWORK FACILITIES-
WHICH THE SERVICES PROVIDED.
WHICH MITIGATES THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE YOU SUBSTANTIVE
MODIFICATION TO MOST ASPECTS OF
THE BILL PROD. FOR ALL TO RAISE
TO THE FAR OF THE IT'S- YOU WITH
MATH. CONSTRUCTED CUTS TO COMPLY
WITH THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF
DICKA. AND THEY HAVE FAITH LEAD
HERE TO ITS PROVISIONS SINCE
OFFERING THE SERVICE ACROSS THE
STATE. UNFORTUNATELY IS CURRENT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY. SAFE K<c.cyan></c>
SAFE HARBOR PROVISIONS THAT U.
VERSE HAS RELIED UPON SINCE
ACTION. THE REMOVAL WHICH COULD
OPEN THEM UP TO NEW
INTERPRETATIONS AND THE BROAD
AFTER OF EQUAL. YES YOU NEED
NATURE OF DIRECT TV PLAN. AND
THE OF OWN OR CONTROL THE
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE ON WHICH
THE SERVICES DELIVERED. IF YOU
WORSE WORK FOUND TO NOT BE IN
GOOD STANDING THEY WOULD HAVE NO
RESULT NO RECOURSE TO RESOLVE
THE CONCERNS WE'VE ALL MET WITH
ITS AUTHOR AND HE RELATE THESE
CONCERNS TO HIM. AND WE DO HOPE
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH HIM TO
GET ARE SET TO GET THE A MEMBERS
TO ADDRESSES VITAL CONCERN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ROCKET I EFFORT
. FAILED TO MENTION WHEN I POINT
TO. IT AS YOU AT BROAD
DEPLOYMENT BY ALL INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS DIFFICULT ONLY
APPLIES TO. THE VIDEO OPERATOR
THAT HAS A VIDEO SERVICE IT DOES
NOT APPLY TO ALL BROADBAND
PROVIDERS SO YOU'RE NOT
CAPTURING EVERYONE WITH THIS
BILL. ANYONE THAT PROVIDES
BROADBAND FIXED WIRELESS SERVICE
OR ANYONE WHO'S NOT PART OF A
VIDEO FRANCE. NOT COUNTED SO.
YOU HAVE- DESPITE DESIGN THIS IS
ANTI COMPETITIVE ANTI BUSINESS
AT SELECTING WINNERS AND LOSERS
SO I FELT THAT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT WE WILL- LOOK TWO
SAUDI AND INVITE M. ANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AGAIN JUST STATING
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION. HELLO
YEAH YOU CAN PULL THE MIKE SO
THERE YOU GO. GET ANY MONEY ON
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HI SHAYNA ENGLAND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT. WHAT YOU AND SALAS
ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN POLICY IN
SUPPORT. THREE ZERO KIND
REPRESENTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
. CAN MEET HERE ON BEHALF OF
COMMON SENSE MEDIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND JEFF DEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT WE WILL THEN ASK ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION TO PLEASE JOIN US
AT THE MICROPHONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MORE TOP
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR EITHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF. PORTNER
HEART ARE THERE WERE NO MORE OF
THAT ORDER FOR VAST. MONNING
TOWN ALL THE BILL'S WE GET A
PRESS- THANK YOU- THANK FOR
BRING THIS WORD I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO ADD
EQUITY AND WE HAVE RIVER VIEWS
OF HOW WE DID THIS I THINK YOU
KNOW I WOULD HOPE YOU WOULD
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION WHAT COMES. I HAVE
THIS KIND OF BILLS COMING
THROUGH. AND THEY'VE GOT NGUYEN
WE ALREADY KNOW IT ONLY COVERS A
FRACTION OF THE INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE PROVIDING
BROADBAND. AND WHAT WE SHOULD
HAVE AS WE SHOULD HAVE
REGARDLESS BECAUSE SO MUCH OF.
OF THE- THE VIDEO STREAMING
SERVICES ARE BEING CONVERTED TO
BROADBAND AND THEY ARE BEING
USED FOR BROADBAND WHAT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK IS TO HAVE A
CONSISTENT PROCESS. ACROSS ALL
THINGS JUST BASED ON THE
LICENSES. I THINK SOMEBODY
FIGURED OUT OF BECAUSE A BACK
DOOR TO REFORM. AND SO I ALWAYS
GET VERY UNCOMFORTABLE WHEN WE
START CHOOSING JUST ONE THING TO
REFORM AND DON'T HAVE A
CONSISTENT PROCESS. ACROSS THE
BOARD BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA END
UP WITH INEQUITIES IN THAT
FRENCH ASIAN SAUCE. HI OF TECH.
YOU'RE DOING BECAUSE IT'S NOT
TECHNOLOGY. SO AND PREPARE TO
GVE YOU A COURTESY I TODAY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION BUT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE STOP JUST
DOING THE DISCUSS STUFF AND WE
LOOK AT. WHAT IS THE PROCESS
THAT WE WANT AS THE LEGISLATURE
FOR ALL OF BROADBAND INTO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S EQUITY. WE HAVE
BEEN THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. US SEEN NO
OTHER QUESTIONS YOU HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD
SECOND MOST. YES WE HAVE A
MOTION AND DO WE HAVE A SECOND.
THE SECOND MOTION AND SECOND
MOTION BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ
SECOND BY MISS WEBER AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BREAKING
MINIATURE. AND YOU KNOW LOOK I
DO APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS- AND I'VE INDICATED
THAT I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM I KNOW THAT THEIR
VARYING ELEMENTS OF WHAT. IT IS
ASKING FOR TO SOME DEGREE-
CERTAINLY DIRECT TV HAS SORT OF
THIS UNIQUE. OPPOSITION IF THEY
FIND THEMSELVES AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT- VAST TO BE CARVED OUT AND
I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S THE WAY
TO GO BUT THERE ARE I THINK
MAYBE SOME OTHER IDEAS. GET TO
WHERE. OF THEIR CONCERN COULD BE
ALLEVIATED SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE A LITTLE BIT CREATIVE
IN TERMS OF. WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE- SO IN TERMS OF THE DOOR
BEING OPENED AND- REALLY SITTING
DOWN AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GO GRANULAR- I'M
CERTAINLY PREPARED TO DO THAT-
AND I. YOU KNOW I CAN ONLY SAY
THAT WHEN YOU. MY BEST RETORT IS
THE FOLKS WHO. HAVE ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL IT'S ABOUT
CONSUMERS. ARE WHO ARE GOING
WITHOUT. IT'S A DOUGHNUT HOLE.
THE DIFFICULT HASN'T FILLED. I
DIDN'T ACCOMPLISH WHAT EVERYONE
AND GOOD INTENTION THOUGHT IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO DO WHEN IT WAS
PUT IN PLACE. AND SO WHAT IT WAS
DESIGNED TO DO WE'RE TRYING TO
NOW MAKE SURE IT GETS THERE. THE
GRANITE THERE MAY BE SOME OTHER
ELEMENTS OF THIS THAT WE NEED TO
EXPAND AND- AND AN EVALUATION
THROUGH THE NETWORK. EVEN
BROADER. BUT IF WE CAN'T GET
THIS PIECE TO MAKE THE MOST
SENSE IT WAS DESIGNED TO DO
THAN. GOING BROADER MAY BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE BUT MUCH BUT I'M
NOT LOSING SOME OF THAT CONCERN-
BUT I DO THINK THAT. AT THIS
POINT TIME AND MAYBE IT'S ALSO
THE FACT THAT THE PANDEMIC SORT
OF OPEN UP OUR VISION TO. THIS
WHO'S FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS. AND THEN YOU BACKTRACK
AND TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHY ARE
THEY FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS.
AND THIS GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY
SO TO ADDRESS THAT. AND SO TO
THAT EXTENT- I THINK THIS MOVES
US IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION- BUT I
AM AGAIN. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU SEE
IT THE NEXT TIME. IT WILL SHOW
THAT. WE PUT SOME ADDITIONAL
EFFORT INTO IT. SO I RESPECT
HEARING. THANK YOU. AND I TO AS%
CHAIR HAVE SEEN THE AMOUNT OF
EFFORT THAT HAS BEEN PUT INTO
THIS BILL. BY ALL MEANS IT IS
NOT PERFECT THERE'S STILL MORE
WORK TO DO- SPEAKING DIRECTLY
ABOUT DIRECT TV WE KNOW THAT IS
A VERY UNIQUE SITUATION AND-
WINE COMMITTED THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT.
PARTICULAR PART BUT I THINK THE
BIGGEST THING IS IF YOU GO BACK
TO. TWO THOUSAND SIX. IMAGINE
WHAT WE WERE ALL DOING IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX WHEN IT COMES TO
CABLE WHEN IT COMES TO. HOW WE
WERE VIEWING NOT ONLY ARE IN OUR
OWN HOMES BUT FOR SOME OF US
MAYBE. SOME OF REMOTE BUT AT
THAT TIME AND IT WAS JUST
BEGINNING AND WE SEE HOW THINGS
OF EXPLODED. AND NOW. WHAT USED
TO BE A CONSUMER PREFERENCE TO
HAVE CABLE NOT HAVE CABLE ALL OF
THESE THINGS WE KNOW OUR
WORKPLACE FROM HEALTH CARE FROM
EDUCATION. FROM JOBS. THIS IS
NOW EAST CENTRAL AND THAT IS A
HUGE DIFFERENCE FROM TWO
THOUSAND SIX SO WITH THAT I
SUPPORT THISBILL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CHAIR RECOMMENDATIONS
AND I. DO PASSED AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK-SILVA HI
QUIRK-SILVA I PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I BOND TIME THAT AMOUNT THIS
DAVIES DAVEY SNOW GARCIA. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I LO LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN%
MAIENSCHEIN I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. VALLADARES
BALLADARES I DR WEBER. A VOTE
CORRECTION. LOOK FOR HER THE
CORRECTION BALLINDERRY. ABOUT
NOW. DR WEBER DR WEBER I. THAT
BILL IS OUT IT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD. THANK YOU. SHARE
THIS WILL LIKELY. SINCE THE
SINCE OUR VICE CHAIR IS NOT HERE
WILL BE HAVING MISTER SHARE THIS
. MMHM.
SURE QUIRK-SILVA PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. GET OUT MEMBERS-
TODAY IS SO CRAZY BUSY SO I'M
GOING TO TRY TO RESET HERE ON MY
BILL PARTICULAR BILL. SIMPLY PUT
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE WILL
ENSURE THAT THE C. P. U. C. IS
WORKING EFFICIENTLY AND AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLY TO BUILD
BROADBAND IN UNSERVED AREAS OF
THE STATE WE HAVE ALMOST BEEN A
BROKEN RECORD ABOUT UNSERVED. WE
KNOW. DAMOCLES SAW MORE THAN
EVER- THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED
SPECIFICALLY IT REQUIRED THE C.
P. U. C. TO REVIEW VIA
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND KNOWN AS CAST OF GRANT
APPLICATIONS WITHIN A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS AND PROVIDES
THAT APPLICATIONS ARE DEEMED
APPROVED IF THE CA. DENY THAT.
WHAT UNDER IT IN DAY DEADLINE-
BOTTOM LINE WE WANT TO MOVE
QUICKLY ON THIS THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THE CPUC TO CREATE A
STREAMLINED A REIMBURSEMENT
PROCESS THAT SO THAT TIME
LIMITED FEDERAL FUNDS CAN SO. OF
AGAIN WE DON'T WANT TO LOSE OUT
pON FEDERAL DOLLARS. AS WE ALL
HEARD AT OUR LAST OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON THE C. P. UC'S
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CAST OF
PROGRAM THEY HAVE A BIG TASK
AHEAD OF THEM TO SPEND TO.
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEND MONEY BACK
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LOOKING BACK AT THEIR PAST
PERFORM FRIENDS EPA C. WILL NEED
TO SICK. AND FOR A THAT. AND FOR
YOU SURE MONEY IT LEFT ON THE
TABLE. TWO WEEKS IF YOU SEE A
DOCTOR A FINE THE ON THE RULES
FOR THE FEDERAL FUNDING ACCOUNT
WHICH BELIEVE IS A GOOD
FOUNDATION FOR STARTING THE
FIRST GRANT CYCLE AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THEM LISTENING TO OUR
COMMITTEE BEGINS. THE DECISION
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RATE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
SO I. HAPPY TO SEE THEM LISTEN
TO OUR OUR COMMITTEE- AND THE RE
WE MAY. DURING OUR HERE. NONE
THE LESS LOW. MUST ALWAYS REMAIN
READY TO ACT TO ENSURE THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM AND THIS
BILL IS A VEHICLE TO DO SO. I
IMAGINE THAT IS THINGS PROGRESS
THIS BILL WILL CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE BASED ON WHAT WE ARE
STAYING AT THE SEAT YOU SEE.
THROUGH AND GET OUT WHAT A- COLD
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND I HAVE YOUR LAN
TO BENSON FROM U. S. TELECOM
HERE FROM THE BROADBAND
ASSOCIATION TO MAKE REMARKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF CHAIR MEMBERS
YOU'LL LANDA BENSON WITH US
TELECOM THE BROADBAND
ASSOCIATION WE ARE FIRST THAT WE
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA FACILITY
BASED WIRELINE COMPANIES IN
BROADBAND PROVIDERS. FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP DURING THE
DISCUSSIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND- THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT FUND AS YOU
KNOW AS THIS BODY. THIS THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE PRIORITIZED.
BROADBAND PRESS LEVEL OF FUNDING
WITH THESE HISTORIC LEVEL OF
TIME SENSE FUNDS. THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND SIR CASS
SAID MUST NOW ATTRACT FISHER
PARTICIPATION FROM BROADBAND
PROVIDERS TO BRIDGE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE AND ENSURE ALL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
BENEFIT FROM TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CONNECTIVITY. AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE IS WRITTEN WILL
DO JUST THIS BY INCREASE IN THE
NECK THE RATING THAT BLABBER
REQUIRED TO CONNECT CALIFORNIA'S
LACK MEANING A SERVE. SIR AND
WAYS AND BILL. WE THAT THE
CURRENT CASH SEPARATE DO NOT
BOTH. TO IT. MANY FORTY NINE
PROVIDES SINCE THE DRAFT. SEES
WITH THAT CURRENT OF THE GRAN AN
APPLICATION AND RESOLUTION
PROCESS DEFICIENCIES THAT
CREATES LENGTHY DELAYS AND
DISINCENTIVES FOR PROVIDERS TO
APPLY AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE
INCLUDES NUMEROUS STREAMLINING
PROVISIONS INCLUDING A DATE
CERTAIN AS WAS TRAINED BY THE
AUTHOR FOR APPROVAL OR DENIAL OF
AN APPLICATION. AND IT RIDE
ISN'T DENIAL AND CLOTHES IN AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE WILL
PROVIDE FOR A MAN WHO MORE X.
THE FOR FUSION OF FEDERAL
BROUGHT FINDING FOR THESE THREE
AND MORE US TELECOM AND IT
COMPANY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS BENSON. NOW
IN OPPOSITION OF WOULD. WE HAVE
. THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
ROLE COUNTY OF REPRESENTATIVE
CALIFORNIA HERE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
WITNESS TABLE. HOME AND PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT IN
OPPOSITION WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
. GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY RIGHT
WITH THERE OKAY REPRESENTS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT REGRETTABLY IN
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION- WE I FIRST WANT TO
SAY- I APPRECIATE COMMITTEE
STAFF- THEIR WILLINGNESS TO HAVE
NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS WITH US.
ABOUT ART SIR THIS BILL- BUT WE
DO RETAIN GRAVELY WITH SOME OF
THE PROVISIONS- IN TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY NINE. PRIME THAT SHOT A
PROVISION UP. THAT CHECK.
A AN APPLICATION WITHIN A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS IF THEY
DON'T DO THAT THEN- THE
APPLICATION IS DEEMED APPROVED.
OUR CONCERN THERE IS THAT. THE
DEEMED THE APPROVAL IS NOT
NECESSARILY BASED ON THE MERITS
OF THE PROJECT THAT'S BEING
APPLIED FOR BUT THAT THE IT JUST
DIDN'T MEET THE REQUIREMENTS ARE
BEING DENIED UP. ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS ARE ARE PRETTY BASS
LINE AND THAT IT JUST MEANS
THAT- THAT IT THE DIAL JUST
MEANS THAT IF IT MET THOSE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
PRIORITIES THAT ARE OUTLINED IN
THE SCORING CRITERIA IN THE- IN
THE FINAL DECISION. THAT THE P.
YOU SEE- ADOPTED LAST WEEK DOES
THE SCORING RUBRIC OR CRITERIA
OUTLINED THINGS THAT THE STATE
FEELS IS IMPORTANT THROUGH THAT
THEY'VE OUTLINED SB ONE FIFTY
SIX IN THE UC HAS ADOPTED SUCH
AS MAKING SURE THE TECHNOLOGY IS
SCALABLE- THAT THAT THE MIDDLE
MILE IS LEVERAGED IN THOSE LAST
MILE PROGRAMS. AND SO. WITH THE
APPROVED AND ALSO THE FUNDING
ROUND STRUCTURE THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE THROUGH THE PROPOSED
DECISION WE'RE NOT REALLY SURE
HOW THAT WOULD WORK IF YOU HAVE
A FUNDING ROUND AND THERE'S AN
APPLICATION DEADLINE- EARLY
APPLICATIONS- COULD BE APPROVED
BEFORE OTHERS ARE REVIEWED IN. A
FUNDING ROUND IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF
THOSE APPLICATIONS AT THE SAME
TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE
APPROVING THE ONE THAT HAS THE
MOST MERIT THAT MEETS- THE
STATE'S PREFERENCES OF WHAT
PROJECTS SHOULD MOVE FORWARD. WE
AGREE WITH- THE CHAIR THAT.
QUICKLY ON THE X. ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE OF THE TRUNCATED
TIMELINE THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDING HOWEVER THE FFA
PROGRAM ITSELF IS TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT IS
UNPRECEDENTED FUNDING AND SO I
THINK WE NEED TO FIND A BALANCE
BETWEEN SPEED AND ENSURING THAT
THE INVESTMENTS OF THESE PUBLIC
FUNDS ARE FOR PROJECTS THAT
PROVIDE RELIABLE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS TO THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN UNDERSERVED AND
UNSERVED- FOR QUITE SOMETIME WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED OUR
WORK WITH- THE AUTHOR AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIND A SOLUTION
THAT. THAT STRIKES THIS BALANCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES THE PROPORTIONAL
OF THE HEARING FOR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN.
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY PLEASE. WE'LL GOOD
AFTERNOON AT CHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS PAM LOOMIS
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS. AND
CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHARLIE
BORN WITH FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS LONG TIME
PARTICIPANT IN THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OR
THE COMMITTEE TERRY NICKELBACK
ASSISTANT VICE PRESIDENT OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR EIGHTEEN
TEA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION AND I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND WORKING
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRUCE JONATHAN THEIR
BILL ON BEHALF OF CTIA THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY ALSO IN SUPPORT. THE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. C. NINE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC.
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC WISHING THAT
SIGNIFY YOUR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME CNN WILL THE CODE THEN TO
PORTION OF THE HEARING FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR KENNY
MEMBERS AS WELL AS ENTERTAINING
EMOTION AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS A CHAIR RECOMMENDATION
OF DO PASS AS WELL. AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE. THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION BY MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
SECOND BY MR HOLDEN. MEDICARE DO
YOU WISH TO CLOSE. I'D THINK
URGENCY AND STREAMLINE ARE THE
WORDS THAT ARE NECESSARY- WHEN
WE LOOK AT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAY PROCESS THAT WE MAKE SURE
YOU GET. OUT AND WE GET THIS
FROM ACCESSIBLE FROM BROADBAND
TO THOSE WHO NEED IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND TWENTY SIX A PLEASE
CALL VOTE. DO PASS ND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK-SILVA HI
QUIRK-SILVA HI PATTERSON
PATTERSON ON BORDER HORVATH.
BONTA SAID ABOUT THIS SAID ABOUT
THIS AYE DAVIES DAVIES I GARCIA
HOLDEN HOLDEN I LO. LOW AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I VALLADARES
MULLIN MY DOCTOR WEBER. THAT
BILL IS OUT AND WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL- AND MR
GARCIA IS PRESENT TEAM BUT WE
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ROLL ON SOME OF THESE
ADDITIONAL BILLS WHERE MEMBERS
WERE NOT HERE. THIS IS FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CERVANTES
SEVENTH THIS I. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. THIS IS FOR.
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT SAID
ABOUT THIS. SAID ABOUT THIS I.
AB. TWENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN
CERVANTES SAID ABOUT THIS I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. THIS
IS FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN ZERO TWO
SAID ABOUT THIS SAID ABOUT THIS
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
MEMBERS WERE JUST WAITING FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA. CAN YOU
CHECK ON OUR CUSTOMERS WITH- ALL
RIGHT HE'S ON OUR WAY. IS WAY.
WELCOME MR GARCIA. SURE. SIX
TWENTY SEVEN. HELLO SIR. RIGHT
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY ONE. OKAY GIVEN THAT
THERE'S A MOTION AND WISHFUL
THINKING IS THAT THERE BE A
SECOND I'LL BE RIGHT BACK IT'S
THE ONLY AFFORDABILITY-
CONVERSATION TAKING PLACE IN
THIS HOUSE- TODAY. AND WE KNOW
THAT WITH THE SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF INVESTMENTS THAT WERE
ADOPTED SUMMER. HAVE THE-
PORTABILITY THE OTHER WITH ME TO
TESTIFY AS FORMER A STATE
SENATOR RICHARD LONGER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTE I
AM ACCEPTING THE COMMITMENTS
THAT YOU PURPORT THANK THANK YOU
. VENTURE VERY BRIEFLY THIS IS
THE MISSING PIECE WE CAN DO ALL
THE MIDDLE MILE OF THE LAST
MILE. IT'S THE AFFORDABILITY
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE I. S.
PIECE OF FOR ANNUAL REPORTS IT
WILL ALLOW FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE ALREADY- TO
QUALIFY TO SUBSCRIBE FOR THE
AFFORDABLE OFFERS WE WOULD ASK
FOR A NAY VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
SHANE ENGLAND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DIGITAL EQUITY INITIATIVE
AT THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION. WHERE COALITION OF
EDUCATION HEALTH ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CLIMATE JUSTICE AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TOGETHER
TO ADVANCE DIGITAL EQUITY. OUR
EXPERIENCE ON THE GROUND ALIGNS
WITH THE FINDINGS OF POLL AFTER
POLL FAMILIES ARE STUCK ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF THE TO DIVIDE
BECAUSE INTERNET IS TOO
EXPENSIVE AND INTERNET ACCESS AS
AFFORDABLE AS TOO OFTEN SUB
STANDARD. IN OUR WORK WE ARE
OFTEN ASKED TO ENGAGE THE
QUESTION OF WHAT AFFORDABLE
MEANS AND WHAT IS REASONABLE TO
ASK ADVICE PIECE. RESEARCH FROM
COMMUNICATION FROM COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE BY POVERTY RATE
THAN WE SELECTED A RESIDENTIAL
ADDRESS FROM THE HIGHEST POVERTY
AND LOWEST PARTY CENSUS BLOCKS
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND SHOP
FOR INTERNET SERVICE ONLINE AT
THOSE ADDRESSES WHAT WE FOUND
FRANKLY SHOCKED US AND I THINK-WILL SHOCK YOU LET'S GIVE YOU A
FEW EXAMPLES. IN BEVERLY HILLS
NINE OH TWO I KNOW AT ONE OF THE
HIGHEST INCOMES OF CODES IN THE
STATE CHARTER SPECTRUM OFFERS
FOUR HUNDRED MEGABIT PER SERVICE
PER SECOND INTERNET CULTURE
SERVICE FOR FORTY FIVE DOLLARS A
MONTH A HALF HOUR DRIVE AWAY IN
THE HIGH POVERTY LOS ANGELES
NEIGHBORHOOD OF LAKE CHARTER
SPECTRUM CHARGES SEVENTY DOLLARS
A MONTH FOR THAT SAME SERVICE.
COME CHARTER OFFERS WEAPONS OF
VERY LOW PAPA SOUNDS BY CENSUS
INFO. INTERNET ULTRA FOUR
HUNDRED MEGABITS PER SECOND FOR
FORTY DOLLARS A MONTH. ABOUT A
MILE AWAY AND A HIGH POVERTY
CENSUS BLOCK IN BUENA PARK THEY
CHARGE SEVENTY DOLLARS A MONTH
FOR THAT SAME SERVICE. SAN DIEGO
COUNTY'S OCEANSIDE IS AN ANTI
SERVICE AREA WHERE IT OFFERS
RESIDENTS IN ONE OF THE HIGHEST
POVERTY CENSUS BLOCKS QUOTE. IN
THAT BASIC ONE POINT FIVE WITH
SPEEDS OF UP TO AND THIS IS A
DIRECT QUOTE FROM THE SERVICE
OFFERING. UP TO ONE MEGABIT PER
SECOND WHICH ON THAT IS NOT
TECHNICALLY BROADBAND. FOR FIFTY
FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH. FIVE MILES
AWAY ONE OF OCEAN. PRESENTS AS
WELL. P. FIVE MONTH PRICE
EIGHTEEN TEAS INTERNET SEVENTY
FIVE WITH SPEEDS UP TO SEVENTY
FIVE MEGABITS PER SECOND. THE
STATE'S DUOPOLY INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS THE SAME VERY HIGHLY
PROFITABLY PUBLICLY TRADED
COMPANIES WITH LUCRATIVE STATE
CONTRACTS REFERENCE IN THIS BILL
OFFER FAST RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE SERVICE THAT FAR
EXCEEDS THE MINIMUM STANDARDS
DESCRIBED IN AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY ONE. JUST NOT TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HOST AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY ONE IS A MODEST BUT
VITAL STEP TOWARDS LEVERAGING
THE MASSIVE PURCHASING POWER TO
INCENTIVIZE ISPS TO EXTEND
SERVICE. AT LEAST APPROACHING
THE SWEET DEALS THEY OFFER ARE
WEALTHIEST COMMUNITIES BUT THEY
SHOULD EXTEND THOSE TO OUR
HIGHEST NEED HISTORICALLY MOST
NEGLECTED COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA-
QUIRK-SILVA FOR LEADERSHIP AND
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR VOTE I VOTE ON TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY. THANK YOU. L. WE WILL
BRING UP OUR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. CCT A.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO WITH
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
SO FIRST OFF WE SHARE THE
OFFICERS. THE COMMITMENT HERE TO
EQUAL ACCESS TO ALL FOR
BROADBAND AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT
OF FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
ALTHOUGH IT'S BEEN POPULAR WITH
THE RECENT PANDEMIC WE HAVE BEEN
OFFERING AFFORDABLE PLANS WHAT
TEN YEARS- IN. HELP CLOSE IN OUR
- YOUR HOWEVER OPPOSED TO THIS
MATTER FOR ONE VERY SPECIFIC
REASON IT IS LEVERAGING STATE
BUSINESS- TO FORCE INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO DO
SOMETHING WE ARE COMMITTED TO
THE NEW- ACP THE AFFORDABLE
CONNECTIVITY PROGRAM AT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S DEBT WE
HAVE OUR OWN PROGRAM- AFFORDABLE
AND ACP'S TO. PROVIDE MILLIONS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF TO EACH
STATE TO ADOPT EVEN ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS BECAUSE ABOUT HIS KEY-
SO WE WANT WITH THE AUTHOR I'M
TRYING TO BEING- BRING HIS BILL
MORE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THE ACP AND WHAT
WE PROVIDE. GETTING UNANSWERED
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IT IS
GOING TO TAKE A VILLAGE IT'S NOT
DON'T IF YOU'RE GONNA DEPEND ON
US JUST TO DO IT AND YOU CAN
HAVE FORCED US TO DO IT BY. A
STATE CONTRACTS THAT THAT IS NOT
I DO PPROACH WE THINK IT SHOULD
BE A JOINT PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP. BOB JUST TODAY. N.
T. S. T. I. A. HAD A WORKSHOP
ABOUT THE NEW. PROGRAM AND THE
HIGHLIGHTED A NUMBER STEPS THAT
YOU NEED TO TAKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU GET THIS LOW. INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS CONNECTED. THE BILL
CREATE. ANOTHER SB EVEN THOUGH
YOU TOOK AMENDMENT TO SAY THAT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WILL
NOT APPLY TO CAL- YES WE'RE TO
CAL FIRE ARE THERE ARE STILL
OTHER SUBDIVISIONS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE LIKE A THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. OF ****
COMMUNICATIONS DOWN IN SAN DIEGO
WE'RE NOT TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF
90% OF HOUSEHOLDS CONNECTED- BY
THE GENERAL ONE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR WHICH IS TWO YEARS- AND
THEN THE- SENDING WHICH
DEPARTMENT CANNELLA BUSINESS
WITH DOCUMENTATIONS IF COMCAST
HAS BEEN SOMETHING FOR HIM TO BE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND WE DID A
CHEAT- THE NINETY PERCENT- GOAL
OF LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
CONNECTED THEN THEY WOULD HAVE
TO TERMINATE THAT CONTRACT SO
USING CONTRACTS TO LEVERAGE- IS
NOT THE BEST APPROACH I THINK
THE BETTER APPROACH IS A
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE PUBLIC AND
THE PRIVATE- WE THE AUTHOR HAS
BEEN VERY GENEROUS AND HAS OFF
PRESS THE PEN TO MAKE AMENDMENTS
TO BRING THIS IN ALIGNMENT AND
WE ARE WORKING ON BUT AS AS
PROPOSE RIGHT NOW- THE BILL IS
IN COP. MS OFFERED IT CONFUSED
CUSTOMER SERVED TYPES OF
PROGRAMS- IS ESTABLISHES THAT
UNLAWFUL RATE REGULATION. BY
SAYING THAT HI SPEECH HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO DO BUSINESS WITH
THE STATE. AND IT CREATES A
PUBLIC SAFETY RISK BUT FOR THESE
REASONS WERE OPPOSE BUT AGAIN
THANK YOU. MR GARCIA- WE ARE
GOING TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT
AND YOU'VE BEEN VERY GENEROUS
WITH HER TIME WITH US AND
DISCUSSING THIS. AND WE WILL
FOLLOW UP. THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WE WILL ASK ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS IN. THE ROOM TO
PLEASE APPROACH THE MIKE.
MEMBERS- YOU CAN YOU CAN PULL MY
MEDICARE MEMBERS WITH US YOU CAN
TELL US ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON DAN
OPEN PLUS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. AND
OUR DIGITAL ACCESS PROJECT- IN
SUPPORT. CAMMIE PIER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE MEDIA IN SUPPORT. ANOTHER IS A DON AGREE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS NOW IN SUPPORT. ARE ANY
OTHER SUPPORTERS IN THE ROOM ALL
RIGHT LET'S SEE IF ANY OF THE-
INDIVIDUALS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
AFTERNOON ALONG THE FENCE AND ON
BEHALF OF US TELECOM THE
BROADBAND ASSOCIATION WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
WE'VE BEEN AND DISCUSSIONS WITH
HIM BUT- JUST KIND OF ON WHAT
BERNIE HAD TO SAY WE ALL HAVE
AFFORDABLE PROGRAMS AND WE DO
WANT TO. CONTINUE AND MANY OF US
ARE OFFERING THE ACP SO WE
UNDERSTAND AFFORDABILITY IS
IMPORTANT AND IMPORTANT TO THIS
BODY WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THE MANAGER JONATHAN YOUR
BILL ON BEHALF OF CTIA THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY ALSO IN OPPOSITION- FOR
SUMMER CONCERNS THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS. Q. ANYBODY ELSE
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT THEN BRING
IT BACK COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
CONCERNS TO THE AUTHOR THANK YOU
A SWIMMER GARCIA THE QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE RECENTLY CONGRESS
APPROVED A FOURTEEN POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR SUB TO SEE A
BROADBAND SUBSCRIPTION FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS CALL THE
AFFORDABLE CONNECTIVITY PROGRAM
WAS THIS- FUNDING INCLUDED IN
THE RATE WHEN YOU CAME UP WITH
FORTY DOLLARS. PER PERSON. WE
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
I DON'T I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE I'M
LOOKING AT THAT MAKE CONSULTANT-
OKAY AND JUST AMONG OTHERS. THE-
MY OTHER QUESTION IS- THAT THE
FEDERAL LAW PREEMPTS ON STATE
RATE REGULATIONS FOR BROADBAND
PROVIDERS. WHERE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY- LISTING A RATE OF
FORTY DOLLARS WENT THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM- EXEMPT AND PROCEED OVER
THIS PRESIDE OVER THAT. NO NO IT
WOULD NOT HAPPEN I THINK UP. I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT NONE
PREVIOUS QUESTION I'M SORRY-
THAT PREVIOUS QUESTION ON THE A.
C. P. THE ANSWER IS YES SO WITH
A FORTY DOLLAR PROGRAM WITH THE
ACP ADDED THAT WOULD BE A TEN
DOLLAR- TWENTY FIVE THREE
PROGRAM WHICH MEETS UP.
BASICALLY ALBERY DEFINITION OF
AFFORDABLE OKAY GREAT AND THEN
CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO THEM HOW DOES
THIS WORK THEN THAT YOU CAN SET
A RATE OF BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT
THE FEDERAL LAW WITH THEIR
PROGRAM THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
HANDLE THE RATE. DEFERRED SO
THIS IS. ACTUALLY SETTING A RATE
AT STATES ACTUALLY A AND EVERY
OTHER STATE THAT HAS A LOCAL
FRANCHISING TO- ALLOWED TO SET.
RULES FOR HOW LOCALITIES
CONTRACT AND CONTRACTING RULES.
THAT ARE IS NOT RATE SETTING SO
CUT COMPANIES COULD CHOOSE NOT
TO SET THESE RATES. AND NOT TO
OFFER THESE AFFORDABLE PLANS.
THAT WOULD JUST ALSO BE A CHOICE
TO NOT HAVE STATE CONTRACT. JUST
BEEN APPRECIATE THIS IS GREAT-
AND THEN SO IF SAID THIS WENT
THROUGH AND IT WAS FORTY DOLLAR
RATE COULD ANOTHER LEGISLATIVE
COMING THE NEXT YEAR AND CHANGE
THAT RATE- EITHER UP OR DOWN THE
WAY THAT THE BILL IS WRITTEN IT
ALLOWS FOR THE PROGRAM TO ADJUST
RATES IN ALIGNMENT. WITH PVC AND
FEDERAL AND ALSO SPEAKS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH PC AND FEDERAL
RULES BUT THERE IS I MEAN. WHAT
BUT SO LIKE V. THEORETICALLY I
CAN'T. I DON'T EVEN TO THE
LEGISLATURE DOES QUITE A BIT-
BUT YOU KNOW SURE THEORETICALLY
JUST LIKE THEORETICALLY THE LAST
SIXTEEN YEARS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT CHANGED YEAH SO-
THEORETICALLY. I APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS JUST QUICK QUESTION
WHAT THEY CALLED FOR BRINGING
THIS AFFORD AS I LOOK TO SUPPORT
THE BILL I JUST HAD A QUICK
QUESTION REGARDING THE INTERNET
SPEEDS I KNOW A CERTAIN BEEN
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THE
BENCHMARK BROADBAND INTERNET
SPEED TO FIND BY S. B. ONE FIFTY
SIX WHICH IS AT ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY SPEEDS JUST. THOUGHT I'D
THROW OUT THERE BUT THERE'S NO
DISCUSSION YOU KNOW SOME SOME OF
COME TO US AND SAID THAT THE
SPEED THAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS
THAT. NOT ADEQUATE ENOUGH RIGHT
NOW AND- WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
BE. REASONABLE RATIONAL. AND THE
LEAVE SOME ROOM FOR THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- BUT- IF YOU WANT
TO ADD TO THAT BUT DATE. I DON'T
DISAGREE BUT AGAIN WE'RE WERE
WANTING- JUST A QUICK START
SOMEWHERE YEAH AND MY AND MOVE-
FROM THAT POINT WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE NO-
CONNECTIVITY. AND THAT'S WHY WE
TOOK SOME OLD ENOUGH
ENTERTAINMENT- MADE BOLD
DECISION RIGHT TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS SAID LAST SUMMER OF
SIX PLUS MILLION DOLLARS. AND SO
WE'RE WANTING TO. GET THOSE
FOLKS ON BOARD BUT REPORTER.
REMAINS A QUESTION FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS GREAT TO SEE THAT
THE FOURTEEN FORTY BUT IT IS A
COMPROMISE OKAY GOOD LUCK
BECAUSE I WAS THERE IS ALREADY A
COMPROMISE YES GOOD THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. AS CHAIR I CAN
TELL YOU THAT- WE HAVE WORKED ON
THIS BILL WE DO HEAR THE
CONCERNS- AND WE ARE GOING TO
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
TO WORK AS FAR AS YOUR QUESTION
THE THIRTY DOLLARS ON THE-
AFFORDABLE CONNECTED IT
CONNECTIVE ITTY PLAN THAT CAN BE
APPLIED TO. THE FORTY DOLLAR
PLAN- SO. ONE OF THE THINGS WITH
THE A. C. P. THAT HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM. IS INDIVIDUALS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF IT NOW THAT'S A
WHOLE NOTHER KIND OF DISCUSSION
AS FAR AS HOW DO YOU GET- PEOPLE
WITH VERY LIMITED ACCESS OR-
MAYBE NOT USING INTERNET MAYBE
NOT EVEN GOING TO I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME. MOTIONS THAT
MADE ME THE VENTS OTHER AREAS
BUT WE HAVE TO DO A MUCH BETTER
JOB IN. GETTING FAMILIES WHO
NEED THIS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS AVAILABLE BUT ALSO ALL
OF THIS ALL OF THE PARAMETERS
THAT COME WITH- JOINING ONTO A
PLAN BECAUSE OVER THE YEARS
PARTICULARLY IN THE PANDEMIC. WE
HAVE SEEN FAMILIES BE OFFERED IF
YOU WANT TO SAY. A LOW INTERNET
PLAN MAYBE STARTING AT THIRTY
DOLLARS AND THEN THREE FOUR
MONTHS DOWN THE LINE IT'S NOW
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS AND- SOME
PEOPLE. REALLY IF YOU WANT TO
STAY READ NINE PRINT BUT THEY
ARE NOW ENROLLED IN THIS PLAN SO
WE HAVE WORK TO DO ON THE
FORCIBLE CONNECTIVE ITTY PLAN IS
REALLY GETTING ACCESS I KNOW ONE
OF THE PROVIDERS TOLD ME THAT-
CALIFORNIA WAS ONE OF THE-%
LOWEST- NUMBERS IN PEOPLE
ACCESSING. AFFORDABLE CONNECTED
TIVITY PLANNED SO WE DEFINITELY
HAVE TO WORK ON THAT PART THAT
BEING SAID- WE HAVE. I THINK A
MOTION AND A SECOND- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE CHAIR RECCO IS AN ONLINE.
THE MOTION IS STILL AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA HI PATTERSON
PATTERSON NO BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH NOT VOTING BONTA. THIS IS ON. HI BONTA I SAID I
WANT THIS SAID ABOUT THIS I
DAVIES DAVIES NO GARCIA. THE
DOOR DOG GARCIA YES I. GARCIA I
. HOLDEN HOLDEN I LO LOW AYE
MAIENSCHEIN RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I VALLADARES NO THERE IS NO. DR
WEBER. THAT BILL IS OUT AND-
THERE'S A COUPLE NUMBERS TO ADD
ON LIVE IT UP THANK. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS- WE DO HAVE-
THE ROLE TO BE CALLED FOR ADD
ONS AND WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES AND WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND START WITH THE ROLL
CALL. WILL DO WITH CONSENT.
BURKE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I BONTA. I BONTA
I. GARCIA GARCIA I. THAT IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS THIRTEEN
ZERO. THIS IS FOR AB TWENTY
SEVEN ZERO TWO BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I BONTA HI BONTA
AYE GARCIA GARCIA I. THAT ONE IS
THIRTEEN ZERO. YES THIS IS FOR
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN DO PASS
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS BOERNER
HORVATH WARNER PREVENT I MEA
BONTA. HI BONTA AYE GARCIA
GARCIA I THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO
OUT TO APPROPRIATIONS. THIS IS
FOR AB. TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT. PATTERSON PATTERSON NO
BONTA HI BONTA AYE GARCIA GARCIA
I. THAT IS TEN I THREE KNOWS THE
BILL IS OUT TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE
BOERNER HORVATH. BOERNER HORVATH
I BONTA BONTA AYE GARCIA GARCIA
I THAT IS THIRTEEN ZERO OUT TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AB. TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY ONE- EVERYBODY HERE
EQUALITY.
RENDON WAIT ABOUT THREE MINUTES
TO FOR ANY ARE OUT ON. THAT'S
MAIENSCHEIN AND WEBER. THAT WAS
ON CONSENT.
MADAM SECRETARY WE CAN LET HIM
SPEAK RIGHT NOW IF YOU WANT TO
GO ON RECORD. YEAH. DR THEY ARE
JUST FRIENDS OF COURSE- ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA TURN THE MIKE
ON. THAT SAME. THE. OKAY GO
AHAD AND TRY- THERE YOU. JOSH
AT THE BAY ON THE TURN TURN
SUPPORTS THE CONCEPT THAT THE
BILL WE HAVE A FEW SUGGESTIONS
AND- WE ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THE SUGGESTIONS.
THANK YOU. THAT'S DID DID YOU
SAY YOU SUPPORT IT ARE YOU.
OUTSIDE A SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALL. VICE CHAIR PATTERSON WILL
BE A STAIN ON BOARD FOR TWO
MINUTES UNTIL WE CLOSE THE ROLE.
THEY'VE. OKAY. OKAY OKAY SO. I
TELL HER WHO'S. THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO BE DOESN'T. I FEEL LIKE
IT'S THEIR OKAY. YEAH YEAH.
OKAY. THE-
YEAH.
THE WEATHER FOR ME.
YEAH WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE ROLE
. THIS IS FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY ONE THAT IS ONE. SEVEN I
THREE NOTE THAT BILL IS OUT AND
FOR AB. TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE.
THAT IS TWELVE ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE ROSE
CLOSE ROGER.